what is going on there reject nation we
see doctor strange this coming monday
but before that we got ourselves another
short clip and another new trailer a
featurette specifically focusing on
wanda maximoff which i hear has new
footage that we gotta check out first
this obviously can't react to this jazz
once we see the movie so we're doing it
now so guys leave a like be very much
appreciated cast a spell to that
subscribe button so you'll be notified
when our review for doctor strange is up
here on the channel let's get to it
[Music]
cool
wow
what is grief
if not love
persevering that is so cool no
i love that the madness of the
multiverse is we get to see different
realities and we see different versions
primarily of doctor strange but we do
see other versions of wanda maximal
i think one division was this journey of
her for the first time taking her own
life into her own hands and it was fun
transitioning from her experience to
this movie we could use an avenger
there are other avengers we'll get you
back on the lunch box
what do you know about the multiverse
we wanted to satisfy the one division
fans
and take them to the next level with the
character they love
that's fun just looking at it from a
different perspective
multiverse
this had his theory [ __ ]
he believed it was dangerous
we need your help
it's magical she owns that character so
well it's a very powerful performance
wow the very powerful character there's
some reveals in this yeah holding the
versions of everyone it gives the
characters unique opportunity to meet
themselves
to recognize qualities that they may
have been blind to
afraid of them
depends on us
[Music]
break that four of the walls
she looked right at us yeah
right at us deadpool wanda confirmed
this movie's gonna be so boring can't
you feel it i am not excited to feel how
boring this movie is gonna be
imaginative too i mean that first clip
was awesome just the different
multiverses that you're going through in
this one quick action scene that's the
multiverse of madness right here yeah
that's all it was right there
the same way you saw x-men origins
wolverine trailer and you were like wow
we're going to seal up nope it's just
the opening
a few seconds and we're on to the story
but i love how you get all this like
crazy wildly animated versions of it and
it looks like you hop through like a
very different time period at one point
like a new timeline something yeah
there's like a cyberpunk looking city at
one point too yeah there's like a mordor
hellscape this looks like mustafar from
the star wars universe hey a same
umbrella company you know it could be i
really love how in a lot of this it's
really feeling like because we usually
rely on dr strange to be one who's in
control and so knowledgeable so much of
the footage and trailers that we've been
getting have been putting it back in the
position where dr strange in a lot of
ways is the one who's feeling like the
fish out of water yeah absolutely like
he's in way over his head in a place
that he should have a good grasp on the
person that we deem as sorcerer supreme
because he's no longer sorcerers but the
one who is he's sorcerer supreme so what
do we rely on to be the know-it-all
there's so much more he has to learn now
everything that we got about wanda too
like they did confirm because there's
all these theories that have been going
around is this just some projection
within her own mind this other wanda
that you see in the trailers i've been
saying and a lot of other people have
been is that that wanda who you see in
the home with the kids tommy and billy
is just a wander from another universe
who seems like she was successfully able
to fulfill and have the family that she
wanted what our wanda was hoping and
aiming for and it seems like the way how
dr strange is able to experience
premonition or memories of other
variants that's what wander herself is
going through so she's gonna be
traversing the multiverse trying to
obtain that so it looks like they're
gonna get into like a big fight those
two wandas because somehow i i don't
know exactly why obviously there's so
much i don't know about this movie but i
imagine that some ability of taking over
that oneness so she can have the
children it seems like our one is going
to be turning more villainous and that
wanda when she's looking down at her and
putting her hand on her face it's like
compassionate torture like i'm sorry you
can't have children but these are my
children yeah
thank you not to take them
and caused your own trauma in my life in
another version of us they mentioned
vision before like viz had his theories
about the multiverse but this featurette
kicked off with what is
grief if not love persevering we still
don't know if vision's gonna show up in
this movie at all but it would be so
cool to actually get him and i still
think that's not the only other wander
we're gonna see oh not at all i mean my
favorite part of this actually was kind
of being reminded of how significant i
think one is gonna be in here because
you know she's in a lot of the ads and
stuff but the impression i always get is
dr strange's adventure it's gonna be
confronting him as a character we're
gonna meet america's chavez wanda's
gonna be involved but this one was the
first one that really made it feel like
this movie will represent an emotional
confrontation and arc for wanda as well
that feels like not only is it a sequel
to doctor strange convergence point for
the greater mcu moving forward but also
a continuation of one division that's
funny because i had the exact opposite
thought i kept feeling like this is
gonna equally be doctor strange and
wanda's movie but the marketing is
limiting us on wanda because she's gonna
have the biggest emotional crux to deal
with here yeah and i feel like it's a
smart choice to lean into the aspects of
wanda that are a bit more sinister and
do play on the grief that we left her in
previously so that the more nuanced and
the more maybe compassionate or maybe
even more sinister versions of wanda
yeah will be a surprise for the rest of
the movie and it makes me just really
excited to see what her journey can
flourish into as well because i guess
maybe it's like a perspective thing like
this made me think that maybe we'll see
through her perspective
more than i was expecting of this
specific movie which i think is really
nice because you know as much as you do
want it to be a doctor strange movie
that does things for him as a character
i am happy to have it be maybe while you
have all these cameos and crossovers and
craziness happening to a a real
meaningful movie for wanda as well that
they could kind of share like a duet or
something like that you know almost like
online i feel like people are more
excited for one of the doctor strange
man i think she's going to be
but she might be like the big highlight
of the movie
and i haven't read what is in the first
20 minutes of this movie i have heard
that it is like really fast-paced and
exciting that's all i've heard about it
i actually don't know what the specifics
are in there but i bet they're online in
a lot of places but guys who are you
most excited for in this film cameos or
wanda leave your thoughts down below you
can subscribe click that bell leave a
like hey let's shout out some patrons
andy funky
punky
lorenzo pretenzo baxter
differently sane and full of shame oh
what the hell levitt odell lauren
american horse is snorin
farin
course my hair was braided by simply
faded leave it to beaver peter
pacheco
delgado
nailed it joanna joe montana saint louis
rogue patrick hogue
cree
with bruce lee
somalia justice 94 what's with all the
fussin justin
what are you starting martin
rosie blows me a weighty baby
darth yoder 66 colin philip joy de vivre
smith jr jen versus ryu and ken
smith
with
tell me your thoughts melanie leblanc
the player eva drastico
found
alive in sokovia jason takes manhattan
dolan
thank you guys
for being here and
hopefully we bring you cheers hooray
see you next
month
[Music]